this morning we started with discussing
president tusks proposals for the United
Kingdom and we all want a compromise
that settles the British concerns and
makes the EU stronger at the same time
we must focus on our strategic interests
that is the united Europe Ian union is
stronger with the United Kingdom in and
the United Kingdom is stronger inside
the European Union the second main topic
we discussed is a migration there are
many issues we have to tackle s to get
control over this challenge and there is
no one silver bullet I think it's
important to say that one thing is
abundantly clear and I was strengthened
by that belief this morning that we need
a collective European solution and not
unilateral solutions in this respect
declarations as we have seen the last
couple of days also from the visigothic
countries were discussed and also I
sensed the need for everybody in that
discussion and also the sense of
compromise that these are not
declarations directed against one or
more States of course we all need and
discuss amongst each other to find a
common solution but separate
declarations of course not d way out of
the crisis we are in this together and
the aim only way out is together I just
wanted to underline also that a lot of
progress has been made in the last
couple of days along the three areas
that are important in the work on
migration the first line is dismantle
the Gateway make the turkey action plan
work by reducing numbers and improving
prospects for refugees in Turkey and in
parallel agree on a broad scheme for
readmission from Greece Turkey and work
at the same time towards a broader
resettlement scheme second line is
support for the European Union's
frontline state Greece and pursue the
rapid settings up of hotspots support
border management and get priority
assistance for migrants in Greece that
requires again also two sides of the
coin it's important that all European
countries chip in on their commitments
for frontex aro and relocation the
searcher line is
it and control the flows through transit
countries in the Balkans again here I
think it's important we work on a
European approach that we prevent a
unilateral race to the bottom the border
control in the Balkans needs to be
strengthened with in a European
framework and there I think the key
words is no registration no rights what
we're talking about is screening is a
procedures according to inter league
international legal and european and
cheng and standards in order to better
control the management of the borders